das ist genau die taktik der verteidiger
zieht ihn so lange in die länge sie
wollen auch eigentlich gar nicht die
aussage vom bushido haben sie wollen
erstmal viele kleine kriegs
nebenschauplätze öffnen und dann um das
eigentliche herum reden und das gelingt
im augenblick sehr gut bushido hat kam
überhaupt noch nicht dazu
aber tatsächlich frage das kann man
natürlich nur so lange machen irgendwann
muss bushido sich äußern oder gibt es
jetzt einen strikten zeitplan wenn sie
lang genug jetzt mit solchen anträgen
zeit schinden dass bushido dann nicht
mehr genug zeit hat um komplett
auszupacken
nein der vorsitzende richter am hot spot
ist schon eindeutig angekündigt er will
zeit nach fortfahren und er will dann
möglich auch heute noch und schüler
hören und da geht es ja dann auch
wirklich um das eingemachte um den
tatsächlichen direkten zusammenhang
bushido und darauf warten